test panne in bayern rund 1000 mit
corona infizierte menschen bekamen ihre
ergebnisse nicht mitgeteilt die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt in ganz
deutschland weiter
machterhalt mit brutaler härte nach der
umstrittenen präsidentenwahl in belarus
geht die polizei massiv gegen
demonstranten vor tausende wurden
festgenommen und schauspiel am himmel
über deutschland regnet es in diesen
nächten tausende sternschnuppen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers so nennt ihn einen und
ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns dass es
ihr nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag und rudi cerne hat den sport
hallo guten amt es sollte alles ganz
schnell gehen in bayern mit corona tests
für alle reiserückkehrer
jetzt ist klar die behörden haben sich
übernommen in der praxis haben sie es
nicht geschafft den getesteten ihre
ergebnisse auch zügig mitzuteilen
eine erhebliche panne für die regierung
so deren folgen weitreichend sein können
an bayerischen autobahn raststätten und
bahnhöfen haben sich bisher rund 60.000
menschen testen lassen
drei viertel davon 44.000 warteten bis
gestern noch auf ihr ergebnis darunter
das ist das problematisch
nach neuesten angaben etwa 1000 menschen
deren test ergab dass sie das virus
haben und möglicherweise ahnungslos
andere ansteckten
petra neubauer berichtet erst heute
mittag bekommt peggy schön ihr corona
testergebnis per mail
es ist negativ nach elf tagen wartezeit
aber zweifelt sie am sinn des tests
ihr bringt es dann auch nicht so ein
test zu haben den ich erst zwei oder
drei wochen später bekomme weil das
virus der virus geht entsprechend weiter
lange verzögerungen und keine
informationen
betroffen waren bis gestern abend 44.000
reiserückkehrer die sich an bayerns
autobahnen testen ließen brisant
darunter auch 1000 nachweislich
infizierte eine solch gewaltige panne
ausgerechnet in dem bundesland das sich
als vorreiter in sachen test sieht
markus söder sagt seine nordsee besuch
ab stattdessen krisensitzung und dann
ein eingeständnis wir können uns auch
dafür nur entschuldigen letzten jahr
waren vorreiter
aber natürlich sind fehler passiert
diese fehler sind sehr bedauerlich und
nun gehe es darum die folgen zu
beseitigen und die betroffenen schnell
zu verständigen
wir haben uns jetzt die kraft darauf
verwendet die positiv befunden
herauszufinden
aber es ist auch so dass natürlich auch
diejenigen die einen negativen befund
haben informiert werden sollen die
werden gerade auch eingepflegt die
anfängliche masse der test willigen
dürfte alle beteiligten überrascht haben
die ehrenamtlichen helfer die bislang
für das pro beziehen zuständig waren
mussten die daten händisch erfassen und
übermitteln weil es keine software gab
ein debakel für dass der
koalitionspartner im bund vor allem
markus söder verantwortlich macht was
mich ärgert ist dass es gerade herr
söder war der in den letzten monaten
immer wieder andere ministerpräsidenten
kritisiert hat ja immer der schnellste
der beste sein wollte und da gehört
jetzt ein bisschen demut auch dazu und
das erwarte ich von den söhnen und
markus söder
er lehnt das rücktrittsangebot seine
gesundheitsministerin heute ab und
bleibt dabei das schnelle einrichten der
teststationen sei trotz aller probleme
der richtige weg ministerpräsident oder
sagt heute auch die aktuelle corona
situation ähnele der lage bei der ersten
großen welle im märz in der tat die
zahlen steigen wieder an und zwar
flächendeckend in deutschland
es gibt aber auch deutliche unterschiede
zum ersten ausbruch in deutschland wie
anselm stern jetzt erklärt deutschland
in diesem virus sommer der wunsch ist
groß nach guten nachrichten doch es
kommen eher schlechte heute vom
robert-koch-institut 1445 neuinfektionen
an einem tag die längere betrachtung der
sieben tagesschnitt zeigt 960
neuinfektionen so viel wie gestern
wir haben durch die heimkehrer aus dem
urlaub einigen neuinfektionen dazu
bekommen aber wir haben auch vermehrt
durch viele private partys
neuinfektionen bekommen und das sind
nicht nur einzelne ausbrüche lokal
sondern eigentlich flächendeckend in
ganz deutschland
das alles verändert die zahlen dieser
virus krise beispiel das alter die
menschen die sich neu anstecken waren
anfang april im schnitt noch über 50
jahre alt jetzt 34
ein grund laut experten wachsende
sorglosigkeit
wir testen relativ viel jetzt auch in
schulen und bei schülern das mag ein
weiterer grund seien und auf den vielen
partys die wir sehen sind ja häufig auch
nicht nur alte menschen sondern gerade
auch jüngere menschen und in der summe
wird das dazu beitragen dass wir den
altersdurchschnitt bei den positiv
getesteten deutlich nach unten bewegt
haben nach oben schnellt die zahl der
tests im ganzen land von 500.000 pro
woche ende juni auf jetzt gut 670.000
mehr tests mehr fälle klar
doch auch die sogenannte positiv rate
steigt also der anteil von positiv
getesteten von denen müssen derzeit
weniger ins krankenhaus denn jüngere
können das virus eben tendenziell
leichter besiegen
trotzdem ist natürlich ein risiko dar
weil man besucht irgendwann die eltern
die großeltern man hat vielleicht im
freundeskreis auch bei jüngeren menschen
mit chronischen erkrankungen mit
vorerkrankung vielleicht arbeiten einige
in der pflege im krankenhaus in den
krankenhäusern sind aktuell aber noch
weit mehr als 8000 intensivbetten frei
das sind dann die guten nachrichten in
diesem virus sommer in deutschland das
virus hinterlässt weiter schweren
schaden für die wirtschaft der
reisekonzern tui ist tief in die roten
zahlen gerutscht der verlust beim
weltweit größten anbieter von
urlaubsreisen beträgt im vergangenen
quartal etwa 1,4 milliarden euro damit
der konzern durch die krise kommt erhöht
der bund seine staatshilfen um 1,2
milliarden auf insgesamt 3 milliarden
euro
wir bleiben noch moment bei der
wirtschaft wirecard lange eines der
deutschen erfolgsunternehmen jetzt sind
manager untergetaucht milliarden
verschwunden wirtschaftsprüfer und
kontrollbehörden wurden jahrelang
getäuscht und betrogen
politisch verantwortlich für die
aufseher ist das bundesfinanzministerium
die opposition will jetzt klarheit wer
wusste wann was für minister olaf scholz
den kanzlerkandidaten der spd ist
wirecard ein heißes eisen florian a
auf großplakaten fanden sie heute nach
ihm genau wie gestern abend in der zdf
sendung aktenzeichen xy
die staatsanwaltschaft münchen 1 sucht
mit nachdruck nach diesem mann jan
marsalek ex vorstand von wirecard
schlüsselfigur des wohl größten
betrugsskandals der deutschen geschichte
seit juni flüchtig derweil fahndet die
opposition in berlin nach hinweisen auf
politische verantwortung etwa bei olaf
scholz als finanzminister für
finanzaufsicht zuständig als
kanzlerkandidat dankbares ziel der
politischen wettbewerber 89 fragen hatte
die grünen fraktionen der
bundesregierung gestellt
in den antworten heute werden sie
mehrfach auf die geheimschutzstelle des
bundestages verwiesen
zentrale prüfberichte so heißt es
unterliegen der verschwiegenheit das was
uns heute vorgelegt worden ist hat
nichts mit voller transparenz zu tun
so geht das nicht so wird das nichts
offenbar hat die bundesregierung nicht
wirklich verstanden in welcher situation
wir uns befinden unklar weiterhin warum
bundeskanzlerin merkel noch im september
2009 10 auf ihrer china-reise für
wirecard war als es bereits öffentliche
zweifel am geschäftsmodell gab und warum
die dem finanzministerium unterstehende
aufsichtsbehörde bafin das unternehmen
nicht deutlich früher kontrollierte das
kann die bafin
sie hat es nicht gemacht und ich möchte
wissen warum hat sie es nicht gemacht
wer hat das entschieden
fdp und linkspartei hatten sich bereits
für einen untersuchungsausschuss
ausgesprochen noch fehlte ihnen dafür
die zustimmung der grünen
nach den heutigen antworten geben die
sich so verärgert dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss unausweichlich
scheint der olaf scholz dann durch den
wahlkampf begleiten dürfte unser
nächstes thema diplomatische beziehungen
zu seinen nachbarn in der arabischen
welt hat israel bisher zu jordanien und
ägypten
jetzt kommt heute die nachricht dass
israel und die vereinigten arabischen
emirate ihre beziehungen normalisieren
wollen
teil der absprache sei dass israel die
mal geplante annexion palästinensischer
gebiete aussetzt
das teilte us präsident donald trump
soeben mit der kronprinz von abu dhabi
bestätigt dass und israels
regierungschef benjamin netanjahu
spricht auf twitter von einem
historischen tag
glück war port beobachtet dass für uns
aus kairo guten abend inoffizielle
verbindungen zwischen israel und den
emiraten gibt es ja jetzt schon länger
inwieweit ist das jetzt heute ein
meilenstein
naja es ist halt offiziell jetzt und das
heißt israel wird künftig botschafter
austauschen mit den emiraten die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen aber eben auch
die sicherheits beziehungen werden enger
werden das ist schon ein offizieller
schritt des dritte arabische land das
jetzt mit israel frieden hat wir dürfen
nicht vergessen mit den nachbarn libanon
und syrien befindet sich israel nach wie
vor offiziell im krieg was entsteht da
jetzt für eine allianz bzw was heißt das
alles für die palästinenser zum einen
muss man sehen der zeitpunkt ist sicher
kein zufall es gibt sicher auch darum
us-präsident trump wahlkampf erfolge zu
bescheren und netanjahu steht zu hause
in israel wegen seiner desaströsen
corona politik unter druck aber es ist
klar israel und die emirate wie alle
golfmonarchien sehnen eine gemeinsame
bedrohung in dieser region das ist der
iran
und dieses abkommen führt sicher dazu
dass man jetzt verstärkt gegen das aus
sicht der israelis und der araber
aggressive vorgehen der iraner vorgehen
wird das reicht ja vom irak über syrien
bis zur hisbollah im libanon aber auch
in gemen
für die palästinenser ist es sicher
keine gute nachricht das westjordanland
ist ja jetzt schon wie die
palästinensische führung sagt ein
schweizer käse mehr als 120 israelische
siedlungen also faktisch hat israel
schon die kontrolle über weite gebiete
und ressourcen dort und man muss aber
sagen dass die palästinensische führung
chronisch zerstrittenen ist und das hat
die golfmonarchien sehr verärgert in der
vergangenheit das heißt konkret in der
zukunft werden die palästinenser im
arabischen lager es noch schwerer haben
ihre forderungen ihren forderungen gehör
zu verschaffen
glück vielen dank für diese einordnung
nach kairo der kampf ums weiße haus
spitzt sich zu das herausforderer
gespannte demokraten trat zum ersten mal
gemeinsam how für diese rolle joe biden
und kamera harris und während beiden
sich als staatsmann präsentiert setzt
harris auf attacke die kandidatin für
die vize präsidentschaft warf donald
trump vor versagt zu haben aus
washington britta jäger
joe biden und kamera herres der erste
gemeinsame auftritt des duos mit maske
im gesicht abstandsregeln und fehlendem
publikum also blieben nur gesten und
worte um ihre botschaft rüberzubringen
wir haben die power jump aus dem weißen
haus zu werfen
camilla ist smart ta verfahren und eine
bewährte kämpferin
ja man ist was donald trump am besten
kann ist denn irgendwer überrascht
darüber dass er ein problem mit einer
starken frau hat dann ist sie dran stark
und wortgewaltig knüpft sich harris
donald trump vor mit geschlossenheit und
kampfgeist wollen sie und biden das
weiße haus erobern und das land von dort
aus wieder einen amerika schreit
verzweifelt nach führung wir haben einen
präsidenten der es mehr um sich selbst
geht also um die menschen die ihn
gewählt haben
trump sei der grund dass das virus
amerika so hart treffe in den
vergangenen 24 stunden gab es knapp
56.000 neuinfektionen rund 1500 tote
56,2 millionen amerikaner haben sich
seit beginn der krise arbeitslos
gemeldet es ist vor allem die
wirtschaftliche lage die in den usa
wahlen entscheidet das missmanagement
des präsidenten im umgang mit der
pandemie hat uns in die schwerste
wirtschaftskrise seit der großen
depression gestürzt
er gibt den staatsmann sie die
angriffslustige aber auch mitfühlende
kämpferinnen das ist das rezept mit dem
die demokraten die wähler in knapp drei
monaten überzeugen und jetzt in der
sendung die aktuelle lage nicht weit weg
von uns hier in deutschland gen osten in
belarus
hier gehen die sicherheitskräfte von
präsident alexander lukaschenko weiter
mit brutaler härte gegen demonstranten
vor schlagstöcke tränengas blendgranaten
und trotzdem versammeln sich immer
wieder menschen gehen auf die straßen um
gegen wahlmanipulationen zu protestieren
hunderte wurden festgenommen für begann
berichtet erleichterung nach vier tagen
haft ist im jahr wieder frei kam einfach
ein auto mann zwang mich mit dem gesicht
auf den boden
ich kam mit kollegen von der arbeit das
mädchen ließen sie laufen aber mich und
meinen freund ich weiß nicht ob er
wieder rausgekommen ist hunderte bangen
vor den gefängnissen von minsk sie
suchen nach ihren verwandten und
freunden hoffen dass einer der
freigelassenen sie wieder erkennt haben
sie meinen sohn gesehen
die sorgen sind groß denn immer mehr
berichte von folter und misshandlungen
durch die sicherheitskräfte
dringend nach außen sie haben mir gesagt
ich solle mich hinlegen das habe ich
gemacht
dann haben sie angefangen mich zu
schlagen ich habe keinen widerstand
geleistet oder so im polizeiwagen und
haben sie mich weiter verprügelt 6700
festnahmen seit der wahl am sonntag das
sind die offiziellen zahlen aus belarus
mit schlagstöcken blendgranaten und
gummigeschossen gehen die einsatzkräfte
gegen diejenigen vor die gegen
lukaschenko es angebliche wiederwahl
demonstrieren einschüchtern lassen
wollen sich viele belarussen nicht mehr
meine stimme wurde geklaut steht auf
diesen roten lettern
ich bin stolz auf das belarussische volk
dass es seine unzufriedenheit so offen
ausdrückt darüber will sich miliz und
rechtsschutzorgane dem einfachen
friedlichen volk gegenüber verhalten
es ist nur eine von vielen
protestaktionen heute in belarus der
chor der minsker philharmonie singt ein
lied über kraft glauben und das hoffen
auf eine bessere zukunft zurück nach
deutschland heute ist der dreizehnte
august 1961 da veränderte er nicht nur
deutschland sondern die welt
die berliner mauer wurde zum symbol der
deutschen teilung und des kalten krieges
von 59 jahren begann die sed-führung mit
dem bau in berlin heute eine zentrale
gedenkfeier die an die opfer erinnert
gegen korona konnten nur wenige gäste
dabei sein
bis zum fall der mauer 1989 starben in
berlin mindestens 140 menschen durch das
ddr grenzregime beim versuch zu fliehen
und jetzt der hoffnungsfrohe blick zum
himmel der sich im moment besonders
lohnt nachts und überall dort wo licht
und wolken nicht die sicht versperrt
auf perseiden das sind besonders viele
sternschnuppen die jedes jahr im august
scheinbar vom himmel fallen benannt nach
dem sternbild perseus was wir sehen ist
kosmischer staub kleine kometen trümmer
die mir 216.000 kilometern in der stunde
auf die erdatmosphäre treffen und dabei
verglühen katrina hat zugesehen
wer die perseiden sehen will muss warten
bis sie untergeht nach milo im
westhavelland einem der dunkelsten orte
deutschland sind sie gekommen
sternschnuppen fans mit mückenspray und
schlafsack bewaffnet das spektakel kann
beginnen
am himmel sind sie praktisch über den
gesamten himmel verteilt und wenn man
sich zurückverfolgen könnte und das kann
man natürlich wenn man ihre bahnen
aufzeichnet dann würde sie aus dem
sternbild perseus herauskommt deshalb
heißen sie auch persien ursache für den
meteorstrom der perseiden ist kombi
zwölf titel auf seiner bahn um die sonne
hat er jede menge staubpartikel
zurückgelassen
jedes jahr wenn die erde an dieser
stelle vorbei kommt und das ist gerade
jetzt regnet es sternschnuppen bis zu
100 in der stunde
man kann sie mit bloßem auge sehen am
ganzen himmel hier aufnahmen auch aus
harpstedt in niedersachsen je dunkler
die umgebung desto besser die sicht
wissen sie im sternen park west
havelland
ich habe das nämlich schon mal probiert
unter war es damals bewölkt und hatte
ich gar nichts gesehen
und heute ist es natürlich ideal für
mich total glücklich irgendwie hier
liegen zu können und wir sind
wunderschöne naturschauspiel zu
beobachten dass es doch noch dinge gibt
die man nicht beeinflussen kann
berührungen eigentlich nur stellen kann
wer die perseiden bisher verpasst hat
kann noch bis zum 24
august auf sternschnuppen jagd gehen so
ich hab mir gerade gewünscht dass jetzt
der sport kommt rudi und da ist ja mit
fußball aus der königsklasse
der rb leipzig startet heute in das
fußball turnier der champions league in
lissabon und steht vor den bislang
größten spiel der vereinsgeschichte im
viertelfinale wartet der spanische
spitzenklub atlético madrid es wird auch
ein duell der beiden charismatischen
trainer werden atletico scoach diego
simone viel erfahrener als der 33
jährige julian nagelsmann aber durchaus
beeindruckt von dessen steiler karriere
das wird ein sehr wichtiges spiel gegen
eine interessante mannschaft mit einem
jungen trainer der dort eine
fantastische arbeit macht atlético kam
gestern erst verspätet in lissabon an
nach den beiden positiven corona tests
im team am vergangenen wochenende
leipzig muss dagegen den weggang von
timo werner verkraften mit vier toren
bester champions league schütze im team
spieler die vielleicht jetzt ein
bisschen im schatten waren und nicht so
die tragende rolle hatten können diese
tragende rolle jetzt bekommen so oder so
gilt nur drei siege fehlen bis zu diesem
pokal den keines der beiden teams jemals
gewinnen konnte hierunter möglicher
halbfinalgegner von leipzig steht
bereits fest gestern gewannen im ersten
viertelfinale paris st germain mit
trainer thomas tuchel in letzter minute
gegen atalanta bergamo
die beiden superstars neymar und kilian
papier sorgen mit ihren vorlagen für den
last minute sieg 90 minute passte auf
marquinhos eins zu eins
dritte minute der nachspielzeit passen
der ex-schalker shooting zum 2 1 sieg
für paris
[Applaus]
mentalität heute haben wir eine
mentalität auf den platz gebracht die
wir in diesem turnier weiter zeigen
müssen denn auch das halbfinale wird
alles von uns abverlangen das halbfinale
das lange außer reichweite schien nach
dem bergamo nach 27 minuten durch den
kroaten cilic in führung gegangen und
lange das bessere team war
paris gehört nun erstmals seit 25 jahren
zu den besten vier mannschaften der
champions league gibt das sind intensive
fußballtage jetzt gerne anschauen auch
aufs wetter da gibt es aktuell eine
unwetterwarnung für nordrhein-westfalen
und gewitter begleiten uns auch morgen
durch den tag wo es trocken bleibt und
wie heiß es wird das erfahren sie gleich
von westend elli der kollege claus
kleber freut sich auf sie im
heute-journal 21 uhr 45
vom gesamten team der heute 19 danke für
das interesse bis morgen und die in
allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die luftmasse über deutschland
sie energiegeladen und weiterer
nachschub folgt aus dem südwesten
allerdings ist diese bewegung der
luftmasse relativ langsam und gemütlich
dementsprechend bilden sich teilweise
heftige gewitter die sich wenig bewegen
schauen wir in die nacht da wird es über
nacht hinweg teilweise gewittern im
westen und auch nach osten hin
im süden sind schauer dabei in den
frühstunden kommt von südwesten her
neuer regen auf und die temperaturen
sinken teilweise kaum unter die 20 grad
marke zum beispiel im westen
deutschlands auch hier in der mitte
kühler an den küsten mit 16 und an den
alpen mit 14
morgen kommen dann die gewitter weiter
in den süd osten voran und haben dann
platzt regen sturmböen und auch hagel
dabei trocken bleibt es nur ganz im
norden und das bei temperaturen bis 31
grad im osten deutschlands hier nur noch
der bereich mit werten über der 30 grad
marke sonst ist es bereits etwas kühler
die nächsten tage gehen weiter mit
gewittern teils unwetterartig zb am
samstag im osten bis 30 grad
ein schöner abend